welcome to bananamores tata cherise is
gonna be your next favorite comedian
guaranteed
yes thank you so much mitzi
yes yes okay okay you guys can stop
clapping now stop clapping
no sit down no thank you clapping stand
up stand up keep laughing yeah
no seriously man i really feel the love
i really really do
gosh after the year we had an entire
year shut down
during a pandemic imagine moving
during a pandemic that's what i did
that's right y'all
i moved into a new apartment last year
right before everything hit
i didn't have furniture for a whole year
an entire year but i made the best of my
situation
oh yes i did every time i walked into my
apartment it was an adventure
you know some days i was the black
cinderella i'll run up my steps
bust into my living room like impossible
my neighbors be like shut the hell up
i'm like impossible
i had a lot of space i would jungle
oranges and stuff in the in the kitchen
you know i had a lot of space
only thing i hated was that air mattress
you ever go to sleep on the air mattress
you wake up ain't no air in it
you wake up on the floor yeah that was
me
you go to the right a little bit the
left come up you go to the left a little
bit the right come up
you try to blow it up in the middle of
the night in your sleep
it was tragic i took their air mattress
back to walmart three times to try to
get my money back
they denied me each time i'm like you
know what excuse me miss
what's the weight capacity on this bad
boy
she's like um you just made it
it was crazy i'm like you know what i
can't live like this anymore
i need to make some money so i want to
get a little creative
and try to you know get a little coin
get a little money you know
i looked into foot modeling yep
i said you know i'm going to put my feet
on the internet and and hope people pay
me
that didn't work out too well see here's
the thing my feet
they're like a diamond in the rough you
know they're not ugly but they're not
cute and they gotta stay done
okay ladies you know what i'm talking
about those feet that those toes always
got to be painted
yep that was me that didn't work out
either
so i'm glad to be back here on this
stage hopefully i can get some funds
going and
buy myself a couch okay
i have a mattress now by the way yep i
do no more air mattresses no more
floating
no no no because even when you want to
have you know a little company you know
i try to have a little mail company
get my groove on i was so embarrassed by
that air mattress
he walked in i'm like hold on wait a
minute you know let me still give you
some you know what i mean we're just
gonna be floating a little bit you feel
me
but that's my time y'all thank you mitzi
for having me and thank you thank you
thank you world
oh that's funny dr sharice you better
come back to bananamores and perform
and also potentially be my best friend
you interested we'll talk